our MGM starting to put a team together
a team that will really start doing some
concrete work on the Stargate franchise
and when will this be announced
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV a
movie channel
[Music]
so as you know I've been able to get to
you first and exclusively with lots of
information about Stargate we told you
over a year ago that Brad Wright was not
going to be involved in this franchise
we've told you that Amazon didn't really
want to work with Bradford a few
different reasons the main of which
being that they just wanted to work with
outside production companies we were the
first ones to tell you and this has
since been confirmed by two or three
different sources that Mark Fergus and
penguin and Parker the guys that did the
expanse were in serious conversations
about taking on the Stargate franchise
that they would be in charge of
developing it doing scripts Etc and even
that Mark Fergus was pushing to showrun
we were the first to tell you that we
were probably going to be getting a
movie first that has since been
confirmed by deadline and now I can be
the first to tell you that actually MGM
are starting to put together a
management team over the last couple of
weeks that have just gone and I'm here
in the next couple of weeks to come
they're going to be talking to lots of
different people and trying to put
together a bit of a management team that
would work within MGM so the team at MGM
that would work with the production
companies that then they're lining up
they will be working on a lot of the
development work they will be working
with the PR Company etc etc a team that
really is going to be the MGM hub for
everything else that goes on around it
regarding the franchise at the moment
that team will initially be looking at
the Cinematic movie that I am hearing is
still the plan but their first job
will be to arrange the announcement of
Stargate at San Diego Comic-Con
now
mid-july is when the Comic-Con is going
to happen I've already told you a couple
of months ago that this is when they
were going to announce
but
I also told you that there were some
voices within MGM and mainly Amazon
apparently saying that well should we
really announce it then for one what are
we actually announcing there's a right
to strike we can't start doing Scripts
for two would it be a little callous to
actually announce a big franchise like
this during San Diego Comic-Con if the
right to strike act to strike whatever
else strike is still going on well I can
tell you right now that as a Friday the
plan is still to announce at San Diego
Comic-Con the main voices within MGM are
saying look we don't think the writer
strike will still be going on by then
this is mid-july I was talking at least
another six seven weeks yet we think
things will be resolved by then if it's
not though we can still announce
something we can still announce at least
that we want to do it we can say look
when everything's sorted we're going to
be putting the full weight of MGM behind
this franchise we cannot wait they're
also going to be announcing things like
the RoboCop plans Etc
so the way I see it and the way the
source that's been speaking to me sees
it unless something else happens that's
really bad say the actors and the
directors and producers Etc end up all
being on strike come the star of July
then I'm certain they'll be re-looking
at this and they'll be changing their
plans but if it looks like over the next
four or five weeks that actually the
writers strike will be resolved and that
hopefully we can avoid an actor strike
Etc then yeah we will be getting the
announcement of this new star great
franchise at San Diego Comic-Con
now I on the channel have released a
couple of videos just with a few clips
from previous Comic Cons just to sort of
give you an idea of what that sort of
thing might look like but also I wanted
to really show you particularly at the
most recent fedcon where there were lots
of Stargate actors almost everybody
turned up and actually how the set up
for the Comic-Con they had a big gate
with a curtain they had all the actors
different coming to talking on their own
talking in panels it really was a
Stargate frenzy how different it was to
sort of like six seven years ago when
actually a couple of the actors were
talking in a half empty Auditorium and
yeah they were talking about Stargate
people were excited but it was nothing
like the excitement that we're seeing at
the moment we're seeing the Stargate
actors going to more and more Comic Cons
at the moment we're seeing a lot more
effort and excitement being put into
those Comic Cons and actually I would
say we're seeing some very excited
energy actors up on the stage because
even if they don't know for sure what's
coming
they know something is but why wouldn't
the actors and why wouldn't people like
Amanda Tapping know and we have spoken
in the past about how we're reasonably
certain that Michael Shanks and Amanda
Tapping have already been at least
quietly approached about this the main
reason
Amazon still haven't exactly decided
what they're going to be doing there is
infighting between MGM and Amazon there
are a lot of people at MGM that have
been pushing for the Stargate franchise
for several years they're invested in
this project now Amazon have come in and
just said yeah we're going to do a movie
we've got the money already set aside
for five or six cinematic movies a year
moose is going to do one from a Stargate
a lot of the people at MGM are like
that's completely different to anything
else we've done before what if the movie
fails what are we going to do then you
know we want a bigger project we want a
series we want all these we have all
these brilliant ideas and This brilliant
team and you're just taken away from us
because really even though there is
going to be a management team at MGM
that's going to be the hub for all this
you have to remember that in lots of
ways Stargate is being taken away from
MGM another company penguin and Parker
we believe is coming in to do the
development work another company we
think that might be Sony is actually
going to be filming the movie and then
the TV series
MGM really is just going to be the name
on the start the Lionel raw and that
might be about it
so there are a lot of people at MGM that
ain't happy about it and they're making
their frustrations well known
so as we speak right now Jennifer salki
has ordered them to begin development
work on a cinematic movie and we believe
a follow-up series
we know that um Courtney Valentina has
then started work on that as well as
work on RoboCop
um Legally Blonde three four five
whatever it is and a few other movies
we believe that that development workers
started in Earnest and that the writer
Strikers maybe held things up a little
bit
we also believe that we're looking at a
cinematic release by the end of 2024 for
Stargate hopefully filming this winter
or we're really waiting for is the
official announcement
and that's what looks like MGM are
preparing to work towards now that
Executives have been talking about this
for a long time the decision was made
about two months ago now they're going
to be doing that negotiations with the
production companies I'm actually being
told that they deal with the actual
Production Company the company will
actually make the programs and the
movies is the big deal at the moment
that actually no doors have been shut
that apparently they have spoken to
Warner Brothers Bad Robot was trying to
push for actually to be the development
company for this as well but it looks
like it is going to penguin and Parker
Sony are looking at this legendary
pictures there's a few others
no final decision according to my source
has been made that he's aware of as soon
as that is made though then I think the
dominoes will fall quite quickly
one last thing that I should say is that
apparently again according to somebody
else I've been speaking to Mark Fergus
is beginning to become a little bit
frustrated by this one of the reasons
why the San Diego Comic-Con announcement
is still planned and they do not want to
push it back any further is because Mark
Fergus has basically been saying I want
this announced soon I want to get stuck
into it I want to be able to hire more
staff for penguin and Parker to be able
to do this project along with other
projects they have on the Slate at the
moment and he wants to get on with it
if they delay any further will it mean
that Mark Fergus might lose interest
it's definitely a risk so just to recap
San Diego Comic-Con is still a go MGM
are talking to people we know at least
three names possibly that I fortunately
can't share with you at the moment but I
will as soon as I can of people that are
actually being spoken to and we believe
that the Cinematic movie is still very
much on the Slate for the late 2024. I
think by the end of two to three weeks
we may know for certain whether San
Diego Comic-Con really is going to be
the announcement or not and we'll also
know I think maybe a couple of the names
of people that are going to be involved
in the development work at very least at
MGM I also wouldn't be surprised if we
start getting more concrete whispers
about what production companies are
going to be involved
so I will get this information to you as
quickly as I can we will keep talking
and keep banging the drum for Stargate
as much as we can
guys you can do your bitter you can go
over to our petition and you can sign to
say that you want Brad Wright to be
involved in this project because the
time is running out if we want Brad
involved the time is now because once
this gets announced if he isn't involved
he never will be but I can promise you
one thing Amazon are looking at things
like fedcon and they know how popular
Stargate is and they know they have to
bring this franchise back
so guys get into the comments to tell me
what you think is the next two three
weeks really as important as I think do
you agree that actually if it's true
that MGM are looking at actually
bringing in a management team for this
project that that really is the biggest
sign we've had so far that this has gone
beyond just planning and they're now
going into the doing
I'd love to know exactly what you're
thinking so again in the comments if you
are new to the Channel please like
subscribe hit that Bell notification it
really helps us out and you'll never
miss any of our new videos also you can
go to patreon.com forward slash
Sidetrack where most of our new videos
appear first and first small
contribution each month that really
supports the channel and you get a bit
of a gift after three months
then you get to see them without the
adverts
as always guys please stay safe and I'm
gonna see you next time
[Music]
thank you